a christmas prince the royal wedding has
just dropped on Netflix and if there's
another thing that 2018 it definitely
needs its another royal wedding
basically I'm a Brit who doesn't really
get the fuss with the Royals in medieval
times sure they used to ride horseback
fight Wars and kill their wives but in
2018 it just seems a bit strange the
Royals to me are the equivalent of
America suddenly decided to give the
Kardashians loads of money so they can
continue their rich lifestyle
it would just be bonkers so naturally
when I heard that Netflix had dropped a
Christmas Prince the Royal Wedding I was
overjoyed Netflix are of course known
for always making oscar-worthy original
movies so the excitement was definitely
there for me the film however is a very
strange one it feels like it was written
by someone who vaguely understands royal
courtship but doesn't really get the
traditions that exist at right view this
film as objectively as possible but it
just seems like there's a lot of key
elements missing and when we're
primarily following a character who
blogs throughout their royal
relationship and who blogs in 2018 am i
right guys it just feels like everything
is as antiquated as the Royals
themselves firstly the Christmas Prince
is actually a Christmas king so you got
that wrong guys secondly where the hell
are the wolves for those who've seen the
first film they'll know that there was a
big scene involving wolves that felt a
little crazy and it turns out that I'm
not the only one who wanted them back
Constance Grady of Vaux stated that the
whole thing was so bizarre that it
immediately imprinted itself into my
heart
so naturally I expected the Wolves to
make their much-anticipated return in
the sequel and yet there are no wolves
the Christmas Prince even says no wolves
I promise
right before a festive horseback ride
through aldo via supposedly wolf
invested mountains and there is not so
much as a howl in the distance the
absence of wolves obviously is
unmitigated
and I agree where the heck ins are the
walls did they get put down did they
become human under the moonlight I just
need to know did they try and recruit
Jeffrey right that's a little shout out
to another Netflix original movie there
guys anyway another big problem that I
have with the film is its presentation
the dress is very outdated and feels
like something pulled off the costume
rack and Netflix studio which it
probably was to be fair that's probably
the most surprising thing about the film
in general and the majority of it feels
like have been there done that that you
don't really expect from a story that is
so rarely touched upon in what media
Emma Stefanski of Thrillist stated that
Netflix knows that the only reason
anyone is watching this movie is to see
two cute people make out and yell at
each other a little bit and then kiss
again and then get married nothing bad
that happens has any real consequences
and the people who are enemies in the
beginning end up friends in the end
everything and everyone in the movie
ends up just fun I completely agree with
that statement and in a way it sort of
sums up the Royals themselves rarely do
they make political stances voice their
opinions on current events or make
statements with any real weight to them
beyond the old casual racist jibe of
Prince Phillip so if you want to see a
royal wedding made by Netflix and I
suppose you get you wish and you will
most likely end the film with a smile on
your face if you wanted to see some
actual drama or weight to the work then
you've obviously come to the wrong place
how the film ranks for you will depend
on your expectations but personally I
found myself bored throughout and
wishing that we could get more outlaw
King than in-laws wedding reception
that's probably the best job I've ever
done so what are your thoughts on a
Christmas Prince - did you enjoy it or
do you agree with my thoughts on the
film being a bit mad comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's other big
film the possession of Hannah grace this
is the channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]